my name is Ted Fisher and I'm a
professor of anthropology at Vanderbilt
University
we define romantic love as an intense
desire for another with the expectation
that is going to live this is going to
persist into the future and that
distinguishes it from lust which is
generally fleeting and also for more
companionship love which doesn't have
that intensity of desire that you want
to possess the other in some in some way
often it's characterized by some sort of
irrationality not doing what a rational
person would do in those circumstances
buying a large gift when you really
don't have the money or going out to a
really nice restaurant or making that
that extra sign of one's love that you
hope will will attract the other and so
really it's it's a bit of craziness
romantic love we're a little bit off
kilter when we're in love and that's the
way we talk about it it's like we're
underwater in some way or where we're
overwhelmed by love crazy and love
well there were there some clear
evolutionary advantages to following him
in love and especially for pair-bonding
a male-female bond and let's think back
you know twenty thirty thousand years
ago when our ancestors are living on the
savannas in Africa human infants are
incredibly helpless and it's very hard
for one person to take care of an infant
and also gather food and hunt food and
run from predators and so having some
sort of core familial group makes lots
of sense and so there are evolutionary
psychologists and biologists who would
say we evolved a propensity for romantic
love to create families so that it's not
just the mother taking care of the child
but a father as well mothers have this
natural need to take care of Jota the
child comes from the mother has to feed
and breastfeed with the mother fathers
are less inherently attached to the
child and so there is a theory that
males of all this propensity to fall in
love so they would stick with their
their partners
an evolutionary biologist would say yeah
we have this propensity that's evolved
that creates all of these positive side
effects for us socially creating
families for example but sometimes those
propensity scan can go out of control we
seem to have a propensity to eat fatty
foods for example and yet in the society
in which we live that's not so adaptive
as it was ten thousand years ago we
should have eaten fat every chance we
got and now we have to sort of fight
against ourselves and resist all of that
fat and so it's it doesn't necessarily
it's not necessarily a contradiction
that we could have evolved a I keep
saying propensity we could have evolved
a propensity for romantic love and yet
it's it's counter adaptive sometimes to
but you do find suicides for example and
that's about as dramatic as it gets a
number of cases in India for example of
young men and young women in arranged
marriages are going into arranged
marriage and committing suicide rather
than spend their life without their
truly beloved
romantic love doesn't have to be between
a man and a woman the evolutionary
theory predicts that that's what makes
sense it just sort of fits neatly but
there's no inherent reason that a man
has to fall in love with a woman and a
woman with a man the same processes of
falling in love we find between gay
couples and straight couples and
bisexuals across the board so that's
important to point out and then along
the same lines as you're saying romantic
love varies enormous ly across cultures
what we imagine is romantic love
probably developed in French courts in
the 17th and 18th centuries and this
notion of that it's wrapped up in love
poetry in sort of the French courtly
troubadours and I would do anything for
my beloved most cultures around the
world that's very foreign it's love is
much more pragmatic in many cultures
around the world including romantic love
it is a necessity that we live together
it's a necessity that we form a family
it's a necessity that we do all of these
things so it's often much more pragmatic
in most cultures around the world
marriages are arranged and we think of
love and marriage what's the Frank
Sinatra song love and marriage go
together like a horse and carriage we
think of that as being natural and yet
in most societies around the world
marriage is arranged and for very good
reasons the arrangers would say my kids
don't know who to marry there they're
too young they're you know they're being
guided by their hormones right now but
we older generation can see what the
best match for our children would be and
in those cases we can find romantic love
evolving after marriage very often we
also find in those cases people young
people who resist their parents arranged
marriages and really follow their heart
as we would say and so well our study
the study that we did several years back
looked at romantic love cross-culturally
the hypothesis of many of our colleagues
in anthropology is that
romantic love is confined to Europe and
to the United States and those those
cultures that have been influenced by us
and in other cultures we find arranged
marriages we find a much more pragmatic
approach and that really isn't romantic
love but we found that even in cultures
with very strict arranged marriage norms
for example we would find elopements we
would find suicides over unrequited love
we would find love poetry so even in
these cultures with very clear models of
how people should pair up there's a
there's evidence of romantic what we
would see is romantic love
and I would actually say in our own
culture probably our manifestations of
love
are informed by Romeo and Juliet and the
latest movies we've seen at the Cineplex
and love poetry and so forth and culture
does even if there's a biological basis
for love and there seems to be lots of
good evidence that there is something
electrochemical going on in the brain
some of these same chemical compounds
are found in chocolate and thus we have
this folklore about chocolate being the
food of love we can do MRIs and see
particular neural networks firing all of
that can still be going on but it's
important not to confuse the correlation
of this brain biology with causation
that that's making us fall in love our
culture the way we're raised our
upbringing our cultural surroundings all
of this is what makes us fall in love in
particular kinds of ways the
expectations of love what do you do on
Valentine's Day we learn that you're
supposed to give chocolates and that
you're supposed to give roses we learn
all of these things and this is as an
interesting a sight we can also learn
not to love I mean children who were
brought up in especially dysfunctional
families often never form romantic bonds
and that's the tragic other side of this
one of the most fascinating among the
Trobriand Islanders young males will
pluck the eyebrows of their paramours or
their beloved's and this it's it recalls
in some ways and I don't want to compare
them to two Apes but it does recall
grooming in some ways and grooming in
chimpanzees and gorillas is a powerful
way of creating a relationship between
two people but I love the plucking the
eyebrows
how love is manifest varies greatly from
culture to culture and we I think often
think of our way as the the only way or
the best way or the natural way
and yet it's not and this is really the
power of anthropology is showing us we
naturally think the way we do things is
best very often and looking around the
world and saying oh among the Zambia in
New Guinea they form homosexual bonds
between men and also have husbands and
wives that's a different way of
configuring families a different way of
configuring love and it opens up the
range of possibility for us to
reconsider the way in which we do things
and it doesn't mean we have to adopt
somebody else's pattern but just knowing
that we we construct this world in which
we live and if we want to we can change
it there are a few notable cases around
the world among Plains Indians before
contact and even shortly after contact
there was a recognized sometimes it's
called a third gender so men who would
feel like they are truly women and they
would dress as women and then they would
take male husbands and very much a
pattern of romantic love falling in love
marrying not having children of course
but still living as husband and wife so
that's one pattern that we find in a few
cultures around the world more often
interestingly of men feeling that they
should be women a few cases that we find
of women feeling that they should be men
and dressing as men but that seems to be
more transgressive for cultures in some
way so that's one pattern
another pattern that we find especially
in New Guinea and in the Amazon region
are men forming very strong bonds
between themselves and sometimes this is
sexual as well as platonic and in these
cultures a very deep suspicion of women
women is seen as polluting as dangerous
as someone who would suck a man's life
blood out of them and so in these
cultures there's still heterosexual
bonds and heterosexual relationships and
that's the norm and yet it's seen as
dangerous and men feel more comfortable
in the men's house where only men can go
and for example among the zombie of New
Guinea that involves it involves sexual
relations so young boys are taught about
sex by having having oral sex with older
men and very odd and sometime then
there's expected than to go through this
progression of having sexual relations
with older men then having sexual
relationships with younger men and then
becoming heterosexual choosing a wife
and living with that wife and having
children very often it's hard for these
men to make that transition to trend
transition to heterosexuality because
women are scary and they don't want to
to be too polluted by women so that's
interesting for this notion that
heterosexuality is natural it probably
is I mean most of the Zambia aren't
don't want to continue with these
homosexual relations for the rest of
their lives some of them do and and
resist pairing up with a woman but even
for the ones who want to be with women
it's a hard transition because they've
learned a different kind of sex those
are the exceptions around the world in
most cultures around the world
heterosexual heterosexuality is the norm
and not only the norm but the you know
the very clearly the norm that that
other sorts of love are looked down upon
but this changes over time I mean there
were we can talk about ancient Rome we
could also talk about times
in the United States or in in Western
European history where homosexuality
wasn't accepted but it also was it was
kind of a screaming secret there were
you know spinsters who live together or
men who liked men and you wouldn't talk
about it in polite company but it was
one of those things that we know it goes
on and we just won't talk about it
so we've seen homosexuality even in
cultures such as their own that have and
even in the very recent past had strong
prohibitions against homosexual love
evolutionarily we would expect I mean if
there is an evolutionary basis for it we
would expect that it would have evolved
to promote male/female bonding
it just makes evolutionary sense but
that doesn't mean that mean the beauty
of humans is we've evolved these huge
brains so that we're not slaves to our
biology anymore
we're not automatons we again we create
our forms of love we make love if we can
use that as a as a phrase and so we can
make love in different sorts of ways
I hope my wife doesn't see this but I
there is some sort of chemistry with
other individuals of course but again I
think it's not something fate puts upon
us we create that we maybe at a certain
point in our lives where we really want
to fall in love even if we don't
consciously realize that there are
certainly fits that are better than
others
and some people like to partner with
people who they fight with some people
like to partner with people who they
never fight with there are all sorts of
variations so I think there are better
fits than others and sometimes people
fall in love at first sight and marry
and make it work and it works
wonderfully but I don't think it has to
be that way I think that we can again
going back to this notion of that we
make love we make what we consider to be
love as a society but also as
individuals and we can make it work and
in fact I would say I don't know I'm
sort of going out on a limb here but I
would say that sort of the the high
divorce rate now and the transience of
marriage or none of marriage long-term
partnerships is partly due to our overly
romantic notions of what love should be
like yeah there are these moments of
euphoria and hopefully they last longer
than not but love is also really hard
work it's compromising it is creating
this this life together with another
person
it is argued tend to like younger women
tend to like particular figures like
large hips positions that are good for
childbearing and large breasts that are
good for breastfeeding and women tend to
like strong masculine big shouldered men
who can take care of their child and
them and there may be some truth to that
kind of thing I think that it's it's
it's too neat of a system there are lots
of popular books written that way
lots of when I teach undergraduates they
love those sociobiological notions
because it's just a nice neat little
system but I think it's too neat I think
that and it varies from culture to
culture at different points in our own
culture we have we've put on a pedestal
more corpulent women in Indian cultures
for example the perfect body style for a
woman is not the hourglass figure but
more of a squat square figure so it's
it's it's too easy for us to extrapolate
from cultural current cultural norms and
then say this is some sort of
evolutionary propensity there do seem to
be more pairings of older older wealthy
men and younger women which evolutionary
theory would lead us to believe but you
also I'm always struck by newspaper
reports of older women going out with
younger men and you see more and more of
that these days and that's that's not at
all what evolution would would have us
think
on the one hand we could say again from
an evolutionary perspective it makes
sense for women to want to remain
committed to one partner or a small
number of partners and for men to have
as many partners as they can because
women are limited in many ways in how
many children they can have and if our
biology is telling us we have to
reproduce that that's our purpose here
on earth we have to reproduce and have
as successful of children as possible
a women only have a period of maybe 30
40 years in which they can have children
then you have a nine-month gestation
period and then you have several months
after which most women are infertile
after they give birth and so women can
only have so many children in their
lifetimes so mathematically if we looked
at this mathematically it makes sense
for women to try and keep a pair bond
going and then for men to keep a solid
pair bond and then to have other
relationships on the side as sort of an
insurance plan a back-up plan and some
would say that men have an infidelity
gene that we are biologically
conditioned to to cheat and again I
would say whether that's true or not and
we really can't say culture is powerful
enough to overcome those things and in
either direction it's powerful enough
that you know many men I don't know if
most I really don't know the statistics
on this but many men are faithful to
their partners and so we can overcome
any sort of biological imperative that
we have not to on the other hand there
have also been times in places where
people don't look askance at having
extramarital affairs and as long as you
were a good husband and you provide for
your family and you know you sleep
around a little bit or you have a
mistress or whatever it may be and not
even you know look at France today it's
much more acceptable for a French
politician to keep a mistress than for
an American
thought about this and I think it's on
the one hand I think that those sorts of
sites try to try to to come up with a
neat mechanical formula for romantic
love that very often doesn't hold up
despite their advertisements claiming so
many marriages from from some of these
these match sites on the other hand if
we we create love and if we think okay
well I generally like people like this
and I have you know the sort of social
life or the sort of job where I don't
run into the kind of people I like it
could be a great way to to meet people's
there's no reason why it couldn't work I
generally like people who like to go to
movies or go to the theater or like
certain kinds of sporting events and so
I want a partner like that and so match
sites make lots of sense that way on the
other hand we can fetishize the match
right we can say if I can just tick off
all of these boxes then that's gonna be
the partner I like and that's setting us
up for a fall because it's still a lot
of work again we have to make this
relationship work it's not as if I find
the partner who has all of these traits
I'm looking for and tada we're gonna you
know violins will rise in the background
and we're gonna live happily ever after
so I think there's a danger there's as
well and just personally when those
sites first came up I always used to
joke with friends and say you know
wouldn't you hate to have to tell people
when you go around and say how did you
meet well you know we met on on a dating
site and now I don't feel that way
anymore I think you know why not it's
it's a perfectly acceptable way of
meeting other people and so maybe we
some of us old-fashioned folks did or
still would fetishize the other kind of
running into somebody on the street or
at a bar or being introduced by friends
and yeah so there's there's no single
formula so I was reading something
recently about the there's a phenomenon
in Japan of young men who take as their
girlfriends these inflatable dolls
and they're not really sex dolls they're
more elaborate than that and they
although they do have sex with them I
think and they will take them on dates
to restaurants and so it it makes one
think art can one have a romantic
relationship with a nonhuman with a
piece of technology or a piece of
plastic and I think so I think I think
the answer would be yes but it's an
interesting question does love have to
be reciprocal to be loved and I think we
can create love in our own minds in a
way that can probably be rewarding
although many of us who are involved in
relationships with real-life people
might not clearly see how
Second Life is a wonderful example I've
read statistics that you know the
extramarital sex on Second Life is just
rampant so it's a it's a it's a easy
outlet for people to to pursue these
things but they seem to be real as well
I mean people have real emotions
invested in this it's not as if it's
just a game and so I think technology
will will probably keep changing the way
in which we envision love in that sense
I think love does play an important role
in our economic behavior and it's
something that we don't allow I think
that the dominant model of human
behavior is based these days is based on
economic behavior that were rational
that we're self-interested and we're
never surprised by self-interest or
selfishness if we read a headline of an
executive that that fudged the books and
took a big payout
we're not that surprised we may be
disappointed but we're not that
surprised and it's because we have this
notion that in economics and in all
aspects of our lives we're looking out
for number one
we're selfish rational actors and yet
love is the opposite of self-interest
it's the exact opposite and so how and
yet we would none of us would say that
love isn't important in our lives either
so how then can we incorporate a
consideration of love of concern for
others into our economic behavior and I
think that this is really important and
in fact we're seeing now a lot of this
neurological research in this
evolutionary biological research that
has said we're self-interested and even
love is a way of promoting our
reproductive success we're seeing now
that maybe empathy is also as deeply
ingrained as self-interest and the
compassion and these would have real
evolutionary advantages as well again
think of you know naked humans on two
legs who can't run very fast living out
in the African savannas 10,000 years ago
we needed to bond together and not just
men and women and babies but groups of
people and so maybe empathy is as deeply
ingrained in our evolutionary history as
self-interest is and in fact we can see
this in we there are mirror neurons in
our brains and so when we look at
another person's face
there are empathy neural networks that
get activated that are very very
important and so this means that we are
connecting with another person and we
feel for that other person Adam Smith is
often considered to be the the patron
saint of economics
and his invisible hand that we looking
out for our self-interest we unwittingly
pursue the interest of everyone but what
we forget very often is that Smith was
also concerned with other interests
sympathy the way in which we treat other
people and he very explicitly said that
we gain satisfaction from seeing other
people be satisfied as well be happy and
we sometimes forget this in our economic
equations
well actually I think we can see it
manifesting itself today in consumer
behavior some of the fastest-growing
areas of some of the fastest-growing let
me just think how I'm going to say this
actually some of the some of the
fastest-growing areas of retail trade
these days are in fair trade products
for example Fairtrade coffee you go to
the coffee shop are you willing to pay
an extra quarter for this cup of coffee
that is Fairtrade now why is that now
some might say you just want to show
your status and I've got plenty of money
I'll just buy the Fairtrade coffee but I
think there's something deeper there
very often in these same coffee shops
there will be photos up of the people
who are harvesting this coffee be it in
Colombia or Hawaii or New Guinea and so
I think that people want to feel a
connection with those who are making the
coffee and feel like they're really
helping improve their lives as well and
I would say that's a form of love not
romantic love but it is a form of love
and we're willing to put our money where
our mouth is put our money where our
feelings are very often in doing that
buying Fairtrade coffee buying
ecologically conscientious products
which is another really huge growth area
of these days so I think we do a lot of
this I think we express love through
economic transactions you could even say
that when you go shopping for your
family at the grocery store that's a
form of love as well we tend to diminish
love in economics from both directions
both the power of love and economic
decisions but also when we use economics
to pursue love are you just buying love
but I think the when we buy a gift for
someone it's more than just the economic
transaction there's really a part of
ourselves in that and not just a gift
cereal for breakfast the next day it's a
way of expressing love economically
love is the opposite of self-interest
love is also not rational and so if we
think of humans as being rationally
self-interested actors love complicates
that both because it's the opposite of
self-interest and because we're not
rational when we fall in love and I
think that this has big implications for
economic and public policy if we can say
how can we create a society well how
about this so France these days is
looking at ways of changing the way they
measure economic success do we do it by
G&P
to the sum of all of our economic
transactions or can we come up with a
measure of fulfillment it can we come up
with a measurement that better captures
our people happy and not happy in this
kind of giddy shallow way but deeply
fulfilled in their lives and that
doesn't always mean increasing GNP in
fact sometimes it could be decreasing
GNP in some ways and I think if we
introduced love into these economic
equations not just in our consumer
decisions but in public policy as well
it opens up a whole new range of the way
in which we can conceive of the society
in which we live and we I think we see
now more than ever after this economic
crisis that markets are not natural
things it's not like a river or it's not
some natural physical force that we've
discovered we create markets markets are
contrivance --is and if we realize that
it means that we can create them in
different ways we can have them serve
our own self-interest
maybe our self-interest is not working
more hours per week but having more
leisure time with our family maybe our
self-interest is not having 10,000 more
square feet of house but living close to
our friends and neighbors so that we can
have more social interaction and looking
at love in those equations really
changes things
you